- Tell me the funniest thing you've done
to get into character.
And I know the answer already,
but I just want you to tell everyone.
- Which one, the farting?
Or was, erm--
(laughs)
'Cause that's not intentional.
What, for Margaret?
- Yes.
- Which one, head back?
I do a bit of head back.
- No, who did you
approach to help you get--
- Oh, the medium.
- Yeah.
- I still think that's really funny.
- It's a bit.
- I love you very much.
(laughs)
- Why not?
- Did you hear, someone in
the last press junket said,
so they spoke to, said,
"So we heard Helena approached a medium,
"did you approach a medium?"
No, 'cause
- She's alive!
- the Queen's still alive!
- Somebody yesterday did
say, really, really clever,
lovely man, photographer, said like
"So, did you get to meet her?
"Did you have to meet--"
(laughs)
- Kind of, he did, but--
- Kind of.
- But, no, I'm very anal
so no stone unturned,
so I thought, well why not?
Give it a whirl,
- Yeah!
- Meet a medium, and see
what they come up with.
And actually, a note--
- Was it helpful, though?
- I think it was, 'cause first of all,
the first thing that she said, was--
- The medium, or Margaret?
- Well, it was via the medium,
obviously Margaret wasn't to spare,
but the medium, who is a friend of mine,
who's done, who's a psychic, and genuinely
helps people--
- And did then get paid?
- She did get paid, but
not an inordinate amount.
So don't, I know where your head's going.
(laughs)
Take total advantage of me.
So the first thing that
she said, apparently,
she said "Oh, Margaret's
here", and I said "Oh, really?"
I was actually doing it for other reasons.
And she said,
"Oh well, we might as well
talk to her, since she's come."
and said, "She's in full regalia."
She said she does like
the fact that I'm playing,
I'm a better choice to the other actor
they were thinking of.
(scandalized gasp)
So, that's good.
- Unless the other actor's watching this.
- Well, I don't know, no, I know.
But that's a very typical thing,
she gives you a compliment,
and then also sort of puts
you down at the same time.
She said it was about
time that I scrubbed up,
that's very Margaret, she said
- Or was it your friend,
just wanting to say.
- Maybe.
(laughs)
Funnily enough, when she
contacted my great granny,
my great granny had the
same thing, it's like
"Enough of this eccentric
dressing, you can't,
can you just be elegant now you're older?"
- You are elegant!
- Today I'm elegant.
- You're so beautiful.
- Oh, thank you, but I
haven't, not every day.
- You are, you're always very elegant.
- No, I'm not.
- Well, I think you are.
- Thank you.
The one thing that I thought
this was a good note from her,
she said "Remember that
the cigarette holder
"is as much a weapon for expression
"as just satisfying my, an addiction."
- Oh that's, that is good.
- That's pretty articulate.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That was about it, scrub up.
(laughs)
Scrub up, and then once I did meet her,
that was another thing, I met her once,
and I do think that's pretty ironic,
she said to me--
- You did meet?
- I met her years ago,
- Oh!
- before she died, obviously.
In my early 30s, and she said
"Oh, you are getting better, aren't you?"
and that was a, I just thought,
that's a very typical, now I got,
there's something rather
ambivalent about her,
she was always, she compliment,
but she'd take away, yeah.
And she was always slightly
difficult to place,
and it's that prickly sort of atmosphere.
- Which is what makes her such a,
- She's a great
- Wonderful character
- person to play.
- For you to play.
- She's complicated.
And she's not easy.
Not easy to be, I don't
think, but fun to play.
And you can do it many, many
ways, and be appropriate.
- We don't have
- She spoke as you'd--
- many ways with the
people that we're playing,
because, well, I couldn't
play the Queen Welsh.
- You definitely couldn't play her Welsh,
but you could try.
(laughs)
That is not Welsh, is it?
I don't know what we are going,
- We're going all over Europe.
- But the (speaks in a foreign language)
No, the Queen is, the
whole point about the Queen
is so consistent.
- Yeah.